switch things over from financial to
mental wealth and my lead is one of the
world's top motivational and business
speakers
jc fernandez spoke to this life
strategist about staying positive
during the pandemic i am so excited
about our next guest who is joining us
here
via zoom his book max out your life i've
read it a dozen times i listen to his
podcast every single week his instagram
account inspires me on a daily basis i
am so excited
please welcome via zoom it is ed my led
how are you i'm great brother thank you
so much for having me
and what a great introduction thank you
so much well the things you do
are amazing and i want to jump right
into everything because there's there's
so much happening
in the world there's so much happening
in the country here in las vegas
how does one stay positive through all
of this
well it's certainly not easy and i know
there's a lot of people suffering and i
don't need to make light of that
but you know there's one way that you
don't have to suffer which is in your
head
you don't have to do that and one of the
things that i would challenge you all to
do is to remember this you don't have to
believe everything you think
not all of your thoughts are true and if
you can begin to question what you're
thinking about you can kind of change
your whole mindset and if you evaluate
what is thinking thinking is the process
of
asking and answering questions to
yourself so the key to changing your
thinking
is to change the questions you ask
yourself and so start to try to take
control of that when they begin to get
away from you
how does someone work on themselves
during this time work on changing their
identity for the positive how do we go
about approaching
something like that great question and
so that's what we should be doing right
now there's two types of people are
going to come out of this there's going
to be the ones that sort of sat around
watch netflix all day and then there's
sweatpants which i did for the first few
days
and then there's those of us that decide
i'm training i'm growing i'm preparing
to be a better version of me when i get
out
and one of the ways we do that is by
listening to podcasts maybe like myself
reading things right now really growing
us
during this time because as you said
your identity it's like a thermostat i'm
in a room right now the temperature set
on the wall
your identity is the thoughts beliefs
and concepts you hold to be true about
yourself
this temperature in this room is not
based on external temperature outside
it's not the external things in our life
to bring us bliss joy and abundance
it's our internal identity one last
question because there's some people out
there
myself included at times i just feel
helpless what can we do when i'm feeling
helpless and i have anxiety
i'm thinking who can i go help who can i
reach out who can i tell that i love who
can i offer
any assistance to and when you begin to
become helpful
you cannot feel helpless in that moment
because you've gotten out of yourself
you've gotten into serving and giving to
somebody else give yourself
give yourself the gift today of doing
something great by becoming helpful to
another person
whoa we all needed that get more life
tips from edmylet on our facebook page